EU ministers of Education have focused  on how education issues can contribute  to economic growth jobs and social  cohesion aiming to increase visibility  of education and training in this year's  European semester The ministers have  agreed to facilitate investment in  modernizing training and education in  the EU they also want to make the  transition from school to the workplace  easier by promoting work based learning  schemes and good quality traineeships be  indifferent to the fact that there is a  link between the knowledge and skills  offered to our citizens and the needs  the demands of the workplace we need to  ensure that the two are interconnected  ministers have also stressed the  importance of providing equal  opportunities at all levels of education  to people of all backgrounds that would  help to improve performance and ensure  that young people and lower skilled  adults acquire the kind of abilities  relevant to today's labor market